hi this is peter russell of university
of story i am
a story doctor in hollywood i also teach
at ucla and pepperdine
but at my own school university of story
you can find what i'm talking about
today
i'm going to be incredibly handsome and
charming he was kind of james bond he
had a little arrogance right
he's brave as hell i'm gonna make a ton
of money i'm gonna be the most
suave sophisticated guy you could ever
meet muhammad ali says he was a better
boxer than he was
he's self-righteous he was a rebel he's
a risk taker he's a superhero he's
using his bravery for light but remember
he's got a core
wound all great heroes do every story is
about that personal wound
it always it always has been it always
will be i always ask my class
stand up right now and tell me the most
embarrassing thing about yourself you
could ever tell anyone the thing that
would make you cringe
horribly if anybody knew it can you
stand up and do that of course no one
will
so i do i stand up and i say
look at my face and when you look and i
don't want you to shout this out but
when you look at my face
tell pick out the worst feature in my
face on the best feature don't tell me
because i did a korean television
interview a little while ago and the guy
goes you have a giant mole on your cheek
and i'm like well
i didn't really want to know that but
just tell me but just have it in your
head what's my best feature and my worst
feature okay
now most people pick one thing out and
then the other and then they start
telling you
oh i don't want to tell them i know what
it is now i say
okay now i'm going to tell you a secret
about myself something
really embarrassing when i was a
teenager
i had this problem and it's it was a
very embarrassing problem
i had something called body dysmorphia
and it i don't know if you know what
that is but it makes you feel like you
either have something too big or too
small about your appearance
i had a wound when i was a teenager
my mommy didn't love me and so because
of that
i had body dysmorphia i thought my lips
were the size of mick jagger
and that was how my core wound
manifested itself
so you can say well so what peter that's
for a therapist couch so that when i
would go into a room
i thought everyone was staring at my
lips they were huge
i'd knock people over with them i
wouldn't kiss a girl in high school
because
i was afraid my lips would get wet and
then they would look even bigger
so here's what i did about that all
these things came out of that wound in
high school for me one
i wore white chapstick okay which made
me appear i was wearing lipstick
now i had long hair and i was in a band
so every time someone would look at me
i'd be thinking
they're looking at my lips they're huge
no they were looking the fact that that
dude says long hair he's wearing
lipstick he must be gay
that's not what i thought i would also
eat my lunch
in the bathroom because i didn't want
people to see my wet lips
so you see that this one wound oh by the
way i got therapy i'm over it now
but this one wound was motivating
all these things they did i wouldn't
have a girlfriend actually i was a
pretty good-looking guy in high school
but i couldn't do it because
i actually did have some but it was a
horrible experience because every time i
kissed them i'd have to use the white
chapstick
so you see where i'm going when i tell
people this story they're like
first of all they're sort of
uncomfortable and then they kind of want
to laugh and then they're
just interested because it's true
anything you tell about yourself that's
true
that's embarrassing is fascinating
to an audience each one of those
compensations for my core wound
is a great scene in a movie you can see
me hiding in a bathroom
unable to eat in front of other people
you can see me turning the lights out to
kiss a girl you can see me putting on
white lipstick
chapstick because i wanted my mouth to
be smaller so
if you can't think of interesting scenes
for your movie or your television show
you gotta go into what wounded you
and what you're doing in secret to
compensate for that
we all have secret lives and they're all
about compensating for our wounds
that's the action that will make a great
story
whether it's film or television we're
not going to be interested in
good looking perfect people who have
like making a lot of money and they're
great and everything they do who gives a
we want to see
people that we can identify with because
that's not
us we've got problems right what makes
you like someone
when they show you the vulnerability
when they show you they are screw-ups
just like you
this is what great stories do
immediately i've got problems
right i want to see my problems
and somebody else with problems dealing
with problems okay
embarrassment truth
ask yourself and you can do it alone in
a room
write down on a piece of paper the 10
most
horribly embarrassing things secrets
in your life you would never want anyone
ever to know
now we all have them you write down 10
of them you don't ever want to show this
to anybody you don't have to
but those 10 embarrassing personal
secrets
will fuel almost all the stories you're
ever going to tell in your life
because every story you tell is going to
come out of
one of those horrible embarrassments
because
they are what's wounded you and they
start when you're little and it's
usually our parents
who wound us sometimes it's a dirty old
uncle
you know sometimes it's a neighbor but
it's usually our parents
so if you can understand what those
wounds are
you're going to be able to write 10
compelling characters
all having behaviors that are
compensations for that wound
every great story starts with a
character wounded like this unless it's
a superhero
that's a that's a separate genre that
has their own rules
but most of the movies you love have a
hero who's wounded
and it comes from the writer himself
and the wounds that he has and how he
tries to compensate for those
that's the physical manifestations in
the story of his behavior and it makes
us
empathize with this weird weird guy
because we're all weird right
we want to know our heroes are weird in
story because it means they're real
the truth about yourself on the page
is the most important gift you have as a
writer
i did an exercise in class where i had
said i will give you
twenty dollars if you take your camera
and go take a picture of your bathroom
right now without moving anything
or take a picture of your bedroom
without moving anything the real bedroom
no one will do it
because it looks awful their real
bedroom but
if you put that up on facebook people
would love it
because that's how you really live so
real stories are about
not the fantasy facebook but the
compelling stories
would be if you took a picture of
yourself when you just got up you took a
picture of your bathroom the way it
looks right now
that's fascinating and the best
storytellers
give you those personal wounds and i say
every storyteller is wounded
and they're trying to tell a story to
heal that wound
we all have a dozen core wounds i i'm
ugly
my mother didn't love me um i i'm
i'm uh i'm badly uh uh socialized
uh no one understands me i go to a party
i i can't talk to anybody no one will
listen to me i'm lonely i'm alone um
i can't reach out i'm married but i'm
i'm not happy because
i really can't be myself there's all
these wounds we all have and we carry
them inside ourselves
that's really what we're always writing
about always
and this is true for untherapized
writers who are very successful even if
they
have never looked at a psychologist's
couch and they laugh at this
when i work with them turns out what
they're writing about
always is their core wound so ask
yourself as a storyteller
what do i what am i interested in what
are the movies i love i guarantee you
when you do that
you'll find out that is your place where
you need to start
when you first see a character you
have his wound now what if you're
wounded as a person what have you done
what's your first of all ask yourself
what's your biggest wound
okay emotionally what's your biggest
embarrassment now what have you done to
compensate for that in your life
let me ask you what's your deepest most
personal embarrassing secret
i'll tell you on the camera there's
there's exactly one
exactly but if you were to tell me now
i would love hearing it why
my only sense would be because then you
could measure your own against what i'm
telling that's right and then go
i guess i'm not that bad after all maybe
only or
i'm not alone okay i'm you're
you're in pain so am i now i understand
you
now i empathize with you
now you're you're like me now it's a
story about me
it's not some wonderful person who's
leading a perfect life that i might
fantasize about and enjoy as a reality
show
or a kardashian show but it's
the deeper part of our lives which is
i'm in pain i i don't have everything i
want
are you like me oh my god you are
thank you now i'll follow you because if
you can get better
i can get better empathizing with the
character
is all about confession if you'll notice
in a great story confession of your core
wound or showing the core wound is
something that happens
almost immediately in great stories you
want to show
the character's wound and his
compensation often
in the first 10 minutes of the show in a
movie that's certainly true
the quicker you show it the better the
empathy will be
for it for the audience don't hide it
guys if you want to give us sympathy for
your hero show his core wound or her
core wound
immediately show it in the first minute
of the story
if you've ever gotten a note that says
your hero isn't sympathetic
it's because you're not showing their
core wound what makes you like someone
not because they're rich or famous or
strong that doesn't want
what makes you like someone when they
show you the vulnerability
when they show that they are screw-ups
just like you
this is what great stories do
immediately and this is what core wounds
always do
this is why it's the nuclear reactor of
a great
character there's three kinds of action
heroes there is the rights of passage
hero who heals his wound for the course
of the movie this is iron man
there is the uh there is the superhero
this is leonidas in 300 he never really
has an emotional change
by the way that can also be a villain
superhero
like jake uh johansen and don jake jones
he's a comic
[Laughter]
or it can be the kind of villain that
you have with jake gyllenhaal in
nightcrawler
he never really changes he just gets
stronger and stronger as a villain
you also have a third kind of action
hero and that is
the hero we're going to talk about today
the anti-hero now he's the guy who
starts out good
but becomes evil for sympathetic reasons
sympathetic is actually more important
than likability
if you look at tony soprano he's a good
example
um it's old now but i think it's the
most brilliant television ever made
i i think if you haven't seen sopranos
you should watch it
okay because it's still the most burly
just like shakespeare
tony soprano is a murderer he's a
horrible human being
and yet we love him why we love him
because he's got this
deep wound in him and it comes from his
mother
and the entire first season of the
sopranos
is about this horrible mother and
how awful she is to tony and even though
when he tries to kill her on the gurney
when she's they're rolling her out of
the out of the nursing home and
everything she's going
he's trying literally trying to get it
with a pillow our sympathies are with
tony
why well here's a big secret of the
anti-hero
which i'll tell you which i talked about
earlier anti-heroes
are great guys who turned bad for
sympathetic reasons right for
sympathetic reasons
michael corleone becomes a horrible man
why he's saving his dad he's saving his
family
right tony soprano is a horrible guy but
we like him why
because he wants to save his family he
wants
the first season of tony's palace we've
seen him he's the ducks are leaving his
pawn his kids are leaving the nest
right he's trying to get his mom saved
into it
into a home she's like ah leave me alone
you're a horrible human being
so the great secret of an anti-hero is
to make the
villains and the people around them
worse
and less likable than the hero
themselves
so tony soprano's mom is the most
miserable horrible human being
ever conceived on television and she
says that he's based on his own mom
but so we love tony because his mom is
just so awful and we thank god poor guy
no wonder he turned into a murdering
psychopath his mom
is awful so that's the critical thing
about making someone sympathetic
and and also likeable yes it's important
but to make them sympathetic you simply
make uh
the other people around them worse
michael carlioni
had to save his dad nobody else would do
it his brother couldn't do it
he had these terrible villains around
him that were shooting
his entire family he had to save
his family and in doing so
he eventually lost his family right just
like tony soprano tony said
ends up killing his nephew ends up
killing the people all around him
probably ends up having his with
somebody shot
in that final restaurant seen around him
but
we have great sympathy for him because
we see his wounds
the wounds are everything wounds are why
we love a character and if when you
first start out writing a story
you should show me your hero or your
character's wounds
the second they get on screen the second
they're on screen
show me the wound that's how you get
somebody to be likable you get the note
your character's not likable which you
get all the time from a producer
that's how to make them likable show
them bleeding
whenever you get a note like he's not
sympathetic what it really means is he's
not believable
why are we sympathetic to a character
because
we understand him that's why
confession's important
but having sympathy for a character we
can sympathize with a complete a-hole
but it has to be believable
right so when somebody gives you a note
character's not sympathetic
don't understand what they're really
saying is they're boring
again figure out why
they're acting the way they do and look
at why they're damaged
give yourself five ways a character
is compensating for their wound that's
always a way to make them believable to
make them deep
the secret of great story is to make us
empathize with someone who's doing bad
things all great story comes from these
kinds of
confessions i call them this is a device
you use
to make your hero compelling it's a
confession
of some embarrassment that you had in
your life we love to see that because
we're all embarrassed
we all feel these wounds we all have
them and we see them in a story
we recognize them as real and we love
that person
and we want that person we're rooting
for that person but
it's compelling to watch someone confess
confession is riveting whenever i
confess a personal wound of mine in a
classroom
everybody's going i've been talking a
long time everyone just stops
there's total silence in the room
they're looking at me
they want to know and this is why you
can't lie
about your core wound because that's
what people want to do oh geez i can't
say the truth so
i'm going to make something up let me
see uh yeah okay
my mom molested me when i was four you
can't make it up
why because we have infinitely good
detectors
as audiences we will know i can always
tell in a story when someone's
telling me something isn't true or isn't
their experience we know immediately
you've got to tell the truth or
audiences
will be bored so whatever your pain is
you can't lie
it's the truth that makes people want to
watch you
oh you're going to tell me something
that's gossip oh i want to hear
why because it's embarrassing
it's true and it's weird that's
every great story every scene's about
the core wound
and about how you're either curing it or
making it worse
and every character in a movie is only
ripping at the wound or healing it
that's all it is
movies are just uh think of think of a
movie
story as a a boxing ring
and the hero jumps into the ring but
he's bleeding
he starts out bleeding and the whole
movie is just
people jumping in with bandages to help
him heal or people jumping in with
knives
to rip it wider open in a television
story
that just continues for season after
season but it's the same
thing oh usually only one wound um
people often think that they can
they get excited about the whole idea of
a core wound which they should because
it really
gives you an original character but when
we in real life by the way we have a
dozen wounds right i mean you know
let's talk about mine or not but
everybody has more than one wound
sure but movies and to some extent
television all they have more lead
are simple okay so you want to sort of
see
one big uh wound uh
but then yes many sim desires come out
of that you know
um tony soprano had one big one my mommy
hates me
what do we do when we have a core when
we compensate and we do it in bad ways
but a bunch of desires came out of that
you know i love prostitutes
i love working at a strip club i love
hurting people
i love to be violent um you know i i
love to
run things i love being a boss you know
i love being a dad
so so you can have many desires just
know that all the desires come out of
the wound and they're often unhealthy
okay they're often unhealthy desires
that's what you want to see
if they were healthy there'd be no show
so
especially in television you get wounded
then you do a lot of unhealthy things i
bet there's something you did in the
last 24 hours that you would hate any of
us to see
some terribly embarrassing thing about
yourself some pain about yourself
you need to write about the pain and
pleasure and the dreams you have of your
own life
don't say that's a cliche every great
movie
ever made comes from that passion comes
from the writer's
passion and love for that story
there's only seven stories in the world
they've all been told a thousand times
the only thing you've got as a writer is
your passion
your love your experience that's what
makes you different
than anybody else and what makes your
story different from anybody else
and people can people i see hipsters who
go now that's not true i'm going to make
them
i'm going to make a cool story about
violence it's just about guns it's just
about knives it's about the cool stuff
that happens
and i'm going to say you're going to
fail that's not going to succeed
tarantino doesn't make movies like that
he makes movies that speak to him from
his heart
that are from his secret desires our
secret desires
our secret pleasures our secret pains
that's what motivates all great story
always
and it always will that's all you've got
as a human being that's the way it's
been that's the way it's always going to
be but now
we return to the a story which is this
everybody gets told you suck at the
beginning
and most people hear it and go you know
what
i guess i do and they quit
everybody gets told it though even the
ones that are really talented get told
it
but the ones that don't hear it or the
ones that just go
yeah i don't i don't suck i'm good
that arrogance that confidence
or whatever you want to call it it might
be you know it might be a neurosis
maybe it's because they're sick i don't
know but that's
in my experience when i look at who
succeeds they've got this rhinoceros
hide
and they persist they persist when
most sane people would say hey go back
to missouri
you know you've got credit card debt
you've been trying
for boom years right you're never gonna
make it
right listen to your cousin listen to
your mother
listen to your accountant who's been
telling you for years what a
stupid thing it is you're doing go back
home
you're done those people go back home
and guess what they're done but the
person who doesn't listen
hey they might end up under a bridge too
because you do need talent it it
this is not a job for someone who has no
talent but
most people i i think
and i'm not sure about anything in life
but for my observation
most people fail because
they don't persist now here's but
you have to actually do the work i know
several people who have failed because
they want to be writers but they don't
actually write they think about writing
every day
and they say they're writing a script
but they don't actually sit down and
write every day now those people they
can fail too
because they're really not trying they
have a dream
but they're not trying peter so how do i
get an
agent how do i get a manager right
that's a question you get asked all the
time
and i think the greatest way to answer
that is
why don't you ask yourself how do i be
good
okay how do i be a good writer because
if you become a good writer
then you can probably get an agent or a
manager you should never write to the
market
the market will always horrify you right
now it's selling our superhero stories
to the studios but if you don't like
writing superhero stories you shouldn't
say oh well i'm going to write one
anyway because you'll fail
you have to write from passion in my
experience
um yes even writers who are
professionals i have to say my
um my my lovely bride
susie's a very successful writer in
south africa
and uh we can cut this if she doesn't
want me to tell this story
but she's very successful in south
africa
as a writer she has a column and she's
created her own voice i mean
she came here and she started um
studying television and oh gosh she's
frowning at me i probably shouldn't say
this
anyway she's saying my god this is hard
and
and and it is hard so film and
television structure
is difficult you're not a genius you
just
are obsessed that's that's what
that's what i did for for seven years i
was a script reader which is a great
way to learn how to tell a movie and
television story because you breaking it
down
and your analysis i teach this at ucla
and at my own school peter russell
scriptdoctor.com
that's peterrussellscriptdoctor.com
for all your story needs and the story
has just begun but this one uh i'd love
to play it for you if you don't mind
sure okay great great i know this feels
like a senate hearing but it's not i
just
i just i didn't do anything criminal
good i remember that
i got my lawyer here anyway okay no this
is about we'll keep it on screenwriting
here and we have a great
clip to play so here we go whoops and
that i'm no good at it um the reason
that i'm
a teacher and a consultant and a story
doctor
is that i my big secret is i don't enjoy
writing screenplays
i tried for a while to do it but it's
not my thing
i i if poetry paid i'd be in the chips
because i'm a poet
that's what i love to write and i also
like to write novels
but years ago the reason i became what i
am is
um i failed to complete a screenplay it
got huge interest
and i realized at the end of it says i
don't like this form
it's just not for me i love analyzing it
i
love understanding how it works i love
helping
other people do it but i don't enjoy
sitting down every day and writing in
the screenplay form it's not my thing
okay yeah great so that was four years
ago
and what i found from from an email from
you is that you've actually completed
a historical tv series yeah and i still
hate writing
okay i'm always gonna hate it okay i was
just telling susie yesterday god i hate
this
um but i'll tell you yes i've had some
success
and what's great about that is is that
it's
here here's the really great thing
because when you're a teacher you don't
really know for sure
my stuff actually helps it actually
turns out to work
the stuff i've been teaching actually
has helped me
which is a huge relief because when
you're a teacher you're often up there
and it's easy to pontificate and say
oh do this in this form try this tool
and but most
some of my tools were terrible but a lot
of them actually worked
but i still hate writing and i i
that's always probably going to be the
case and i think maybe
there are some writers who don't hate
writing who they just
love it and they get 10 in the morning
and i can't wait to get to the desk
but i'm always going to loathe it um but
it is
i guess i'm good enough at it now to get
paid and
so i'll do it it's it's actually
fun to get paid yeah and it's fun
to know that your stuff's actually gonna
be out there it's two opposite things
needing to fulfill a very rigorous
disciplined structure and having the
personality
of a rebellious miscreant who hates
convention
and can't stand following the rules
right
those two elements are often necessary
for a creator
and it's why creators are all crazy
right
because those are opposites you know i
mean
rebels and rule followers are usually on
the opposite end of a scale
so to be able to combine those two that
makes you crazy
i i see it all the time i i think it
really is true
that a lot of people in this business
are insane
i'm kind of insane myself uh i think
it i think it's almost required to have
a kind of schizophrenia
to be a successful creator
a commercially successful creator it's
it's not
it's not easy and so many of my students
are rebels and so when they come into
this process and i'm start showing we
start showing them
tools like yeah that's going to make my
story a cliche
and and the fact is
the most rebellious rule-breaking
directors
uh like like tarantino they
they use these tools the subjects
they write they show are where they
rebel
they show subjects that are crazy that
you wouldn't ever
really be interested in but the tools
they use
are classical are are powerful
are rigorous and they employ them
with the precision of an engineer in
other words
long story short not anymore but i
really
can use my tools to solve story problems
that i'm getting paid to solve so
when they work i'm so excited i'm so
ecstatic
it means all the 20 years i've spent
doing this
is actually paying off for me and also
now i have a little bit more credibility
in when i teach
right because the wrap on teachers is
well you can teach what you can't do
right
yeah that's what you're teaching you're
not doing okay i get it
well now i'm doing so i i can say okay
well yeah but these tools actually do
work so shut up
shut up i i i did it
[Laughter]
we have a structural tool called the
bmoc which is beginning middle obstacle
in climax these are the four points in
any great story where the heroes ask to
change
and they're in every great story whether
it's
star wars or the fault in our stars
or a fast and furious tokyo drift
i found this out years ago analyzing all
movies that
it was equally emc square moment for me
there are four
crescendos in a movie where the heroes
asked to change
and asked to learn the theme of the
movie and ask to learn
how to heal all the things i talk about
the big things i talk about
healing learning the theme um stopping
bleeding
all that there's four times in a movie
story
inevitably that that happens at a
crescendo it's at 30 pages in 60 pages
in
90 pages in and about 108 pages in those
i call the beginning middle obstacle
climax the bmoc
right now that's a structure that is in
every great movie practically you've
ever seen
it's not in a goddard movie okay if
you're writing a french wave movie i'm
sorry i won't be able to help you
that's just a french guy peeing in an
alley for two hours and that's great
right i love those movies but but in a
in a hollywood film structure
is invariably in the story and if it's
not
there's usually something missing it'll
be superseded someday but that's what's
operating now now
that bmoc operates in everything why
does structure matter so much in
television
it matters because people in television
have a short attention span
and you need to give them many different
story plots
because they're also arguing with their
girlfriend they're also looking at their
cell phone their dog wants to get out
and they're also in a bed that they're
uncomfortable in and they're probably
emailing somebody right
all of that's happening when you watch
television it's not true in a movie
theater
just like a pop song no matter how cool
or hipster
has a chorus a bridge a verse
structure right kanye does and you know
uh
rykuter does they all do why
because the human brain is wired
to have a certain set of beats in
any narrative form there's three levels
of story plot
okay stay with me guys this is a little
complicated but you need to know this
because mr robot has them all
and the reason they have them is the
mystery thriller audience wants to be
baffled you ever seen anybody who loves
to do crosswords
they're looking at the new york times
crossword puzzle and what are they doing
they're going oh
oh my god oh my god i don't think i can
solve it oh peter i don't think i can
solve it oh my god
what is that that's the adrenaline that
comes from for you looking at a puzzle
not being able to solve it
then when they do solve one what do they
do they go ah
they get a kind of a dopamine high it's
a kind of an orgasm
because they have now solved the mystery
that's all mystery thriller does for you
it poses a mystery and then it lets you
solve it
okay not my genre when i went to
inception i was like what the hell's
happening i'm gonna go i'm gonna leave
the theater
but the mystery thriller audience loves
that mystery
now that means they crave a complicated
story so there's three
stories in mr fillers there is the
distraction plot
that is what you see quickly in act one
that
looks like the real crime that's going
on in the story but it's actually just a
distraction
the second plot is the emotional change
in the hero that helps him solve the
crime and the third plot is
the real crime what's really going on
that does not get revealed until
act five in the story now it's hidden
people say ah hollywood so formulaic is
they're looking at bad unimaginative
stories with characters you've seen a
thousand times
with situations you've been in a
thousand times with care with within a
world you've seen a thousand times
set but the structure the commercial
structure
is there because it's beautiful the
bones are beautiful
you can take different bones out put
other bones in
but there's an appeal below the surface
of beauty if you look at what we
consider to be beauty
if you took a a skeleton you'd see there
was a conformity to the bone structure
now you can put whatever you want on top
of that bone structure
you can make uh the person uh a tunisian
you can make them indian you can make
them american indian you can make them
whatever you want but the bones below
that determines whether or not they're
beautiful
i think structure of story is like the
bones beneath
the the the face it's what
we're instinctively drawn to as human
beings
and that doesn't change but what changes
what makes things unique
are is it a new world are these
characters we haven't seen before
is this guy have a wound that we haven't
seen before and remember we have three
plots and a mystery filler i know i'm
talking a lot about
this i know it's confusing you can watch
this several times
the plot in a mystery thriller that's
really critical
is that there's an emotional change in
the hebrew throughout the story that
helps him solve the crime
that's the key in all great mystery
thrillers whether it's movies or
television
if you don't have good news bad news
raising stakes
and and uh ticking clocks on every page
of your story
your story's gonna be boring guys we're
not gonna have time today to talk about
the four act structure in television but
it's important you know what it is
it's seven different beats
per act the a storyline has
15 to 16 of these beats the b has seven
to eight
the c has three to four and the d has
why do i talk about this if i'm not
really going to talk about it
because you need to look at my
television lecture or somebody else's
television lecture
to make you understand that every act
every
hour-long drama has this same structure
no matter how crazy you are
and how much you want to break the rules
the reason it's there is to entertain
the audience in a rhythm like a pop song
has a bridge a chorus a verse
even the craziest ones right they all do
because it entertains the audience so
we're not going to talk about that all
now but you need to understand that's
true and each beat
has a hero an antagonist and a fight
inside the beat
a beat is two to three minutes long it
is a single dramatic act
and there's 28 of them in a hour-long
television show
and they're cheap tricks by the way it's
good news
uh i'm giving you 20 bucks bad news i'm
slapping you
ticking clocks is just a bomb a bomb
ticking down
it's a gun pointed at someone these are
not
sophisticated tricks they're simple
but the greatest artists use them in
all of their best work in california we
have these
these uh uh vanity license plates right
and and
in a vanity license plate i think you
get seven letters right
and in that seven letters you've got to
be witty
okay you can't go oh man you know what
it's such a cliche to have seven letters
my vanity plate's gonna have 42. because
if you take
if you make the vanity like 42
characters long it's not going to be
funny
when you say you know if you have a
seven letter word
that says let's say you're driving a
corvette and your seven letters are
two inches right okay that's funny
got me to laugh if it was a 42 letter
plate you'd go
hey i drive a vet because i have a small
penis
is that funny no no no because the form
is too big
so commercial form is what we delight in
we wanna
the limitations of commercial form
produce
the the entertainment right the fact
it's a half an hour
means you must cram certain things in it
and the delight of an audience in a
commercial art form is
how are they going to cram something
we've never heard about and is witty
into this limited commercial form that's
what commercial art
does mentors heal
heroes core wounds that's what they're
for
and that's what he's going to start
doing now in television they don't heal
completely but they heal a little bit
what we want to see in a story is a hero
learning to heal and even if he doesn't
heal completely because he doesn't in tv
he's still going to go on a journey
towards healing a little bit
the critical difference between film and
television is in tv
the hero doesn't heal but he heals a
little bit and then at the end he gets
ripped open again
so every week he's going to heal a
little bit and then get ripped open
again every week 150 times
but the bmoc works at the exact same
places in the television hour than it
does
in a movie there's just an
extra m because there's an extra act
so let's take a four act television
structure the bmoc
it's bmmoc the oc
the obstacle point is the point when it
looks like the year is going to lose
and in a movie this is right at the 90
page point
let's take a movie everybody knows star
wars uh luke gets to the planet
the last rebel planet uh uh darth has
followed him there with a homing beacon
he's got a death star he's gonna blow up
the whole damn thing there's nothing
luke can do about it there's just a
little few star fighters
and he's got a death star that's it the
movie's over
and then of course what happens r2d2
says hey
i stole the plans of the death star
there's a little hole you can fill a
missile in if you really get close
and luke you can the only one get that
missile in that hole if you use the
force not your computer
and so the obstacle point is all is lost
and the climaxes
luke learns the theme of the story
luke will you use the force to rescue
the princess and save the republic
he puts his computer away all the other
starfighters used it they couldn't get
the missile in
he puts his computer away he's learned
he hears oh we want to say luke
use the force not the computer and he
puts the
missile in the whole climax so the
obstacle point is always lost
and the climax is luke you did it
in breaking bad the obstacle point is
he's making meth in the desert jesse
comes back out with the
crazy eight and the other uh criminal
they're gonna kill them both walt's in
his underwear
he has no defense he's gonna get shot
and killed but then he says
i'll teach you i'll teach you how to
cook i'll teach you how to cook my
recipe
and the guy goes really yes
and they go in the rv and walter throws
poison into the thing
whoosh and the climax is he kills them
both and becomes
the mass murder he's gonna be for the
next 150 episodes
so that's the climax so the o and the c
point
and i'm not explaining this well i'm
sorry but it's in my lecture online
it's a complex little tool but it works
so great
it's like a little engine that works any
television
structure you want just like it did in
film so what did i learn
when i started learning about television
everything i learned in movies works
every element that i learned about in
movies
works in television the structure is
just a little more complicated that's
all
does everybody know what a log line is
because a long line
in television and a log line in movies
is very different
in a movie log line you're telling the
story of how someone changes
the hero in television you're simply
showing the hero's
goals and his obstacles in the way it's
a very different log line
i urge you if you're writing television
to do what we call breaking the a story
log line over and over again
because it's literally creating your
story by asking yourself what is my
story and putting it in a frame
that's what makes great story well in
television if the heroes don't heal
then why do we want to watch them
because they're going to surprise us
with new character revelations
anybody remember that great moment in
the sopranos
when janice and richie who are about to
get married are having a quiet evening
at home and she's cooking him dinner and
they're both irritated but it's just
another night
suddenly janice starts irritating richie
suddenly richie starts irritating janice
and suddenly richie
hits her he backhands her he's never
done that before now they're about to
get married
that's a big surprise we've never seen
richie do that before
it's not a change in his character it's
a revelation
because we have a new conflict she's
irritated him and we also can see that
this is going to be the way it's going
to be for the rest of their marriage
he's setting her up to get hit every
night and then he sits down to have his
dinner and he says
what are you gonna do cry now and he
starts eating
now janice is about to surprise us a lot
because janice walks out of frame when
she comes back she's got a gun
he looks at her and he sneers janice
i've got no time for this boom
and she kills him right there now that's
not janice healing for god's sakes or
really even changing
she's just showing us a new facet of
janus as a badass
that is the critical way television
heroes
give us excitement and it's why we want
to watch
television not to see them heal or even
get worse because we
all believe really the world's both that
it's
got poison in it and it's also got good
in it
ninety percent of the time um it's about
a hero who doesn't have a change or
compelling change
the hardest job for a script writer and
actually for a producer
or a director anybody involved in a
story is to make a really cool character
that you might think is great
you might have a really cool setting wow
that's neat we're in the south pacific
you've never seen that before
and this is a cool character but they
don't know how to change him
how to take him from one place to
another so time and again
what i do is talk about that point out
this guy isn't changing or if he is
changing it's not believable
um uh and and so when a bad movie is bad
often it's because this hero's change
is not there it's not real it's not
compelling
um and sometimes you'll have a wonderful
setting
and you'll have a wonderful hero but he
just
doesn't change correctly a movie log
line
is about a hero who changes it's the
entire
story of the movie from the perspective
of the hero well
let's say that her change needs to be
let's make it a personal story let's say
that she
doesn't have love okay so she's wounded
most great hollywood movies are about a
wounded hero given a chance to change
okay that's what they are so let's say
that the reason she's wounded is that
her wound and it's always about a wound
in a story that's any good we all have
wounds i call them core wounds our
parents usually gave them to us so let's
say that her wound is that
she can't connect to anybody okay she
can't be intimate with anybody she just
doesn't feel it so she's a bartender so
really
she doesn't have to ever have intimate
relationships
she just has lots of relationships with
the people at the bar but they never go
any further than that
okay if she has uh any intimacy at all
well she doesn't and she's not in it
with her family either okay
so what's going to change her what's
going to make her change well
you have people who are going to tear
her wound wider open
let's say that that's the owner of the
bar who doesn't want her to change at
all
loves the way she is and and and tells
her now though
that hey we're changing our bar our
bar's going to become a coffee house
and it's going to be really important
that you talk to the people who come
in that's going to be as a barista i
want you to really establish friendships
and it's all about that and by the way
here comes
someone who's a consultant who's going
to help you change
uh and be more friendly and also more
intimate with the clients
well she really will hate that she'll
hate that she'll want to quit but she
can't quit she makes so much money doing
this
um so then you're going to have also
a person on the other side you're going
to have a let's call her
an impact character who's a relative who
says to her hey
your sister's getting married and i'm
making this a personal story
your sister's getting married and your
sister wants you to come to the wedding
and she also wants you to help me
make this card up that it's a whole
family and everybody's in it
and our our heroine resists that too now
i don't want to do that at all i i don't
want to be involved in the family i
don't even know these people
so right there you have this personal
setup where you have a girl with a core
wound who's i can't be intimate
and you have her put in a position where
she's going to be forced to have to be
intimate
or she's going to wind up in a tragedy
and then you give a villain into the
story and the villain is a guy
who is just as disconnected from people
as she is
and he tells her you know what let's
just have sex
nothing else no intimacy at all and she
says great that's fantastic
oh i finally found the person of my
dreams but as
we get into the second act she begins to
fall in love with this guy
and she also begins to realize when
she's in that bar
that she's beginning to feel the lack of
intimacy and and
it's hurting her that she can't connect
to people
so she's learning from this
person who's there as a consultant how
to connect because she's bonding with
her
at the same time she's falling in love
with this
villain who is gonna now tell her when
she reaches out to him
i don't want to be with you in fact i've
got a family so goodbye
that's going to push her to change to
heal to reach out to understand she
needs intimacy so in the third act
the third act will be all about her
helping her sister's
wedding reaching out when her sister say
goes into crisis and says suddenly i
have cold feet i don't want to get
married
now our heroine's going to have to
minister to her and say wait a minute i
think you should
because intimacy is good i've just
learned it's good i'm gonna tell you
one of the times in your life you've
been happiest haven't they been with
other people
so she's actually learned through pain
and learned through the fact of being
rejected by someone just like her a
mirror
that she does need intimacy that she
does need
to reach out and be with people now
that's a very small
story very emotional intimate story in
the end she reaches out to her family
but she doesn't have to fall in love
this is an indie movie this is a cool
kind of movie all she has to have is a
small change toward understanding
i need intimacy i need and in fact
that's the story of up in the air
that's a very famous movie with george
clooney it's all about
and it's a character study it's just
about this guy who's disconnected from
people
who by being pushed by villains and also
pushed by helpers
learns how to become connected to people
that's
now if it was a superhero story um or if
it was a tragedy
in the end she wouldn't learn that she
wouldn't have a change she'd try to
change
but then because she fell in love with
someone who was a bad
teacher she would be so crushed that in
the end
she retreats and decides she's not going
to love she's going to go back to the
bar
and there's no movement at all that's a
tragedy in fact that's the story of the
wrestler
that was a a great movie a few years ago
tries to change looks like they're gonna
change but has a mentor that's so bad
that when the mentor uh uh rejects them
and moves away
they simply fall back into their old
patterns
and in the wrestler he goes back to
wrestling and he dies so
you can build the story either way it's
all about who's there on the journey
with them
impacting them that tells you and shows
you and them
whether or not they're going to be able
to heal and change or if they're going
to fall back into a tragic
end come on baby get in the siraglio
do it our way you can still be original
[Laughter]
most riders have strong suits and and
suits
that aren't as strong and character
change has to be at the heart of almost
every kind of movie unless you're making
a superhero movie where the
hero doesn't have a change and other
things have to happen there but so
it's a long-winded way of telling you
that to change your character in a story
is
everything and that's what i do if it's
not there
but the superhero is huge now and so
the superhero model involves
a very particular tool we can talk about
at some point i don't know if you might
go into it now but
what i decided was because several
people had taken a pass
at jack johnson and i think someone
actually is uh
making a movie i'm not very big but
and i don't think i'm giving away
anything here secrets wise
um a superhero the reason a superhero is
fun to watch is not for the same reason
most heroes are fun to watch most heroes
are fun to watch because
they're wounded and they've got some big
bleeding
wound and and we're going to watch them
heal it we're going to watch that's the
story superheroes know
superheroes are not wounded they're
superheroes
um often the old-fashioned superhero the
uh
in three hundred leon zack snyder's 300
leonidas
he doesn't have a wound it's like oh my
mommy hurt me and i i gotta
figure out how to do that no in 300
he's an old-fashioned superhero because
all the reason we want to watch
an old-fashioned superhero is to see if
he can lift
the bigger weight that the villain's
putting on him at the four crucial
points of the story
the villain just gets bigger and says
hey
you could lift that 300 pounds huh think
of the villain in a super
as a deranged trainer at gold's gym and
and
you he said all right so you're gonna
lift 300 pounds all right or you did
that okay so
at the 30 page point you lifted the 300
pounds okay 60 page point
we're going to put 900 pounds on there
can you lift that
so the superhero secret of the superhero
story that kind of superior story
there's several kinds
is that can he lift the bigger weight
the villains put on that
rack that's it it's not about psychology
it's not about core wounds
what does that tell us remember i said
that a
hero is misusing his superpower
at the beginning of the story and
sometimes
your superpower and in television that's
another thing you need to know
usually in television your hero has a
super power
and usually that super power especially
at the beginning is being used for wrong
reasons bad purposes for instance
don draper and madman has a superpower
he's
insanely seductive okay he and he's
seductive as a womanizer and he's
seductive
as an ad man but it comes from the fact
that his mommy didn't love him
right he feels unlovable so
all the things he does he uses his
superpower
for bad reasons because he's wounded he
seduces women
right he he does ad campaigns for
cigarettes and horrible things
and he's amoral as an ad man because
he's misusing the superpower but the
superpower came from his wound
if he hadn't been wounded i'm not
lovable he would have never
become a great seducer he wouldn't have
needed to
so the the super power is related to the
wound
but the dis but the but the the things
he wants
come out of the unhealthy desires
uh of him trying to make the wound
go away trying to feel better about the
wound in a story
it's about people's flaws and their
embarrassments and their
pain there's nine questions i always ask
when i'm when i'm first talking to
someone at their tv show
first of all what does stevie do it
gives us a great world we need a great
world because we're going to be in it
for 150 episodes right
so what's a great world right i would do
an exercise where i say to you
you give me a great world and don't tell
me it's new york city i
i want to know a specific neighborhood
of new york city what's the great world
because great television
is always about a great world now uh if
you want to talk about new york then
give me a specific world in it like
there's a show called billions
and this show is brilliantly written
it's probably the best television out
there right now
and it's all about billionaires how they
make their money
and how they live their fascinating
lives right uh another fascinating world
the assassination of gianna versace
that was a world of versace uh fashion
world in miami
and then this guy who became a serial
killer his world
and never seen it before um so carbon
black
is this really cool sci-fi show it's
about a cool to the future where people
can change
bodies right so they have sleeves they
call it so
your world you want to ask yourself what
is the world of your show atlanta
is probably the coolest show on
television right now
and it's all about this african-american
milieu of middle class lower middle
class atlanta
and this sort of slacker guy in it and
how he's gonna
survive in this slacker world never seen
it
before stranger things that's the world
of the 80s
and that's big nostalgia for kids that
are 20 30 right now
people on their bikes without helmets
television sets that were tubes
with rabbit ears so the world there is
absolutely about the nostalgia yeah
so big question what's your world
that's what we want to see fantasy
continues to be big
um i hate it but zombie is a world that
just continues to be true true blood
vampires romance
continues to be good black comedy world
of shameless
uh white trash so worlds
are extraordinarily important in your
show
the next question i ask is do you have
a um do you have a
theme that matters what do you want to
say about the world in your television
show
for instance a a show like um
essence of anarchy which is a great
world of world motorcycle show
the theme is if you have a bad mom or
dad you're going to be screwed
you need to have a good parent you need
to be mentored well he's not
and that means the entire show is about
how the hero of the show
fails because he doesn't have a good mom
and dad his dad's dead
his mom's horrible and and so this truth
about life is often what hipsters
ignore when they're writing a story
they're like i want to write this story
i call it the weed and speed it's going
to sort of motorcycles and violence and
razor blades and
people smoking crack and that and i'm
like okay great
ten minutes i'll love it then what's the
truth about life
you're saying sons of anarchy kurt
sutter's brilliant writer why
because he's got a theme that this
hero hero who drives a motorcycle who's
tough who does all the things that
you're saying you want to see the
violence the sex
the motorcycles all that stuff but every
episode is about this guy
struggling with the fact he doesn't have
a dad what
how do i live my life without a dad or a
mom
and he never figures it out and he's
screwed because of it so
theme answers the question and orange is
the new black which is a brilliant
show what's the theme well you better
know yourself piper
can't doesn't know if she likes girls or
boys and the whole show is about uh do i
like guys do i like girls i don't know
who am i i don't know you tell me who i
am so that's a great theme too
so downton abbey has a theme which is
that the lower class
is rising and we have to understand how
it's rising
that's the theme of every episode of
downton abbey okay
so theme is in strudel in in the wire
which is probably the most
the intellectuals uh a wet dream of a
show the wire
david simon in his story bible and
that's something you should also have
when you're pitching a story
um his message is this
this story i must read this because this
is the front page of the story bible
this story is about the human condition
about it's not just a police show
it's a show about how we have taken the
urban
uh uh underclass and have jailed them
and tormented them and torn them apart
in our stupid drug war
okay that's his theme and
it's a social theme and that motivates
every every uh uh one of those
uh episodes so if you don't have that
and it works even in a sitcom
you're not gonna have a show that works
so what are you passionate what do you
believe in i ask my students
sometimes what do you believe in like i
don't know i mean that's not important
i'm going to write a hip
story no you're not you're going to bore
us
the next question is why do we want to
watch the show every week
okay every week we got to watch a show
100 episodes
so you need a great question right in
breaking bad what's the
great hook question every week how bad's
walter going to break what's he going to
do this week oh god he's going to be
even worse
okay making a murderer hey did he do it
or not that's pretty good question you
know
every week we get that orange is the new
black is piper ever going to figure out
if she likes girls or boys no she's not
gonna
so but this question continues it's the
hook it's the great question of the show
mr robot can eliot take down the big
corporation
okay game of thrones which family is
going to win
every episode is about that right and
what's the theme of game of thrones by
the way that's kind of important
the theme is do you have to be
evil to be a great leader
okay that's the whole question
for every episode right so that's an
important question
okay so the next one is genre let's not
go into that because
i teach that it's a structural thing but
you need to stick in your genre
uh what parents are your show like in
television if you're going to write a tv
show
you got to ask yourself what are the
parents of the show who what shows are
like this that you've seen before
and my hip students i was like ah peter
i don't wanna my show's like nothing
else ever on it's like okay well then
it's not gonna go
it's not gonna get on and even even if
you want it
to be completely different from
everything we need to understand what
you're reacting to what did you hate
okay you gotta have parents for the show
and it'll help you
build your show if you do okay so then
the next question
and this is super important is
well how do i say it um
what is the question that
torments the hero
forever that will never be resolved
what's the unsolvable dilemma for
the hero that will never ever be
solved and that is
in mad men it's i
am unlovable and the things i do to make
myself lovable
make me so uncomfortable that
i run away don draper seduces woman
after woman after woman and mad men
but every time they fall in love with
him they always do he runs away
because he hasn't softened his basic
dilemma which is i'm unlovable
okay so that is the unsolvable
dilemma okay even in buffy the vampire
slayer it's
i just want to be uh alpha and be
in high school and be popular
no you're a vampire i don't want to be a
vampire 150 episodes of that
unsolvable dilemma okay um
bra breaking bad walt's dying he's got
to take care of his family
how does he do it he becomes a drug
dealer and destroys his family
so the thing that makes him want to take
care of his family
the way he does it destroys his family
okay true detective rust versus rust
knows the world is meaningless
marty believes there's a lot of meaning
in the world
how do they resolve that well they do in
the end because remember it's a
mini-series
it's like a movie so in the end they do
both believe the world's a great place
but that's not classic tv okay
so will walt protect his family or
destroy it
um we'll russ view um how can good
prevail in a world that's run by the
strongest that's game of thrones
how can we have a world where there's a
good leader when
it's the worst people who always win
right
unsolvable dilemma maybe in the end you
know the two people with the ikea rugs
on their back they're going to learn
how to do it but but for the whole
seven eight years they don't have it so
what is the irreconcilable conflict in
your show
what is the dilemma that will never be
resolved
uh that that that will keep people
coming back
and obviously that has to do with their
core wound so the next question is
what's the big core wound in your hero
how does that work in your television
show
um and there's many different ones um
and and it's always about that
unreconcilable dilemma madman i'm
unlovable
tyrion in game of thrones i'm unlovable
everything he does is because of that
walters is i'm weak and my father you
say never corner a weak man
they'll turn out to be really strong uh
wade and deadpool by the way because
this is true also in movies i'm ugly
a randall in this is us which is a great
serial show we haven't talked much about
randall is i'm not part of this family
right my skin color is there i'm not
really part of mine
pete and sneaky pete i'm not part of a
family great car wound jessica jones and
jessica jones
i'm not safe this villain can get me
he'll always get me
so core wounds are the
nuclear reactors of your show they
really are
and they have to have daenerys core
wound in game of thrones is
i'm powerless and we see the entire
first season
for daenerys she starts out as this
little sex slave for her brother
she's given to this warrior as a sex
object
by the end of the season she's walked
through fire
and hatched dragon eggs so her
powerlessness is beginning to go away
but it will continue through the entire
run of game of thrones
i'm powerless is she getting powerful
she's beginning to
but that'll take a long time so these
are just the beginnings of the questions
that i would ask
there's many others but this is a start
when you're writing television and they
are different from film but those
those start when i would start talking
to someone about their tv show
these are the questions i would ask them
at the beginning products
sell because they're great stories
sell because the product in it is flawed
right that's the big difference this is
the most exciting time i think
in history for television at least in
the u.s
why has tv become this explosive golden
age
susie hates me saying a golden age but i
think we are in a golden age of
entertainment
and it's because now there are no
constraints
on what you can see in sex what you can
say
television has no more rules because the
stories are getting so much longer and
look
you can tell everybody is neither a good
guy nor a bad guy everybody's got a
combination of traits in them right
so a movie can't really show you that
there's not enough time you're either
good or you're bad
so what you saw in a in a story like
true detective
is what i call going from saving a cat
to killing the cat because that's where
we are now we are
reconstructing dark heroes that people
want to watch
why do people want to watch dark heroes
television and the longer form
can show both the good and the bad
inside of
all of us it's a more sophisticated
model of human behavior i think we're
just getting to be more sophisticated as
people to know that people's stories are
complex
i'm not all good i'm not all evil i'm
mostly evil
but there's some good in me but that's
the mix
and so longer form art can
give us a more complete picture of what
humanity's about
nobody's all good and nobody's
all bad and that's part of why superhero
movies are failing because that's not us
we all know
as people that we are not only good
we're all so bad
and so killing the cat simply means
showing us
dark heroes who are like us
we can accept that we couldn't 20 30
years ago television was just about
good people and really bad people well
now television has become more like the
russian novel of the late 19th century
where
tolstoy was writing where people aren't
good or
bad everybody's a villain and everyone's
a hero
so this dark hero is more like us
television today i think is
is better because it's more
sophisticated and actually
shows us more of the world than tv did
30 years ago you know movies were cool
because
they showed us stuff tv couldn't movies
were cool in the 70s because we could
see nudity
we could see violence we could see
obscenity we could see adult themes that
tv just
couldn't tackle right surprise
jaime lannister is super evil and he's
also banging his sister
movies lost its edge over tv because
now we can see all those things on tv
right that's part of white tv school
those rules don't exist anymore and i
think
when an art form is at its freest
it can also be at its best
when it's able to show everything about
a society
now we're not there yet there's still
things we can't show on tv television
shows a surprise have you ever known
somebody for 15 years
don't they just get weirder and weirder
the better you know them
finally they're so weird you can barely
take it well you're just
learning who they are you're weird too
by the way
and you don't reveal it to someone at
the beginning it's a
process that's why television story
works so well
and why in a lot of ways it's a more
sophisticated form than movies
television gives us characters who
actually are a lot more like
us in real life and i think that's
another reason tv is powerful
in a way is that we don't heal
generally all in in a month or two
months
it's a lifelong process so
wounding and bleeding is kind of the way
we go through
life so television shows us in a way
in a way there's more depth in
television than in movies although
movies has
have have real depth too but we can see
week after week
facets and surprises of characters that
we would never have time to see
in a movie right when you can't talk
about something
you can't face it
and when you can't face it you can't
heal it
and so i'm not a big fan of political
correctness and i really believe
television is at its best when it
doesn't have anybody saying
oh you can't do that no no no you can't
say that
no no no that's that's beyond bounds and
i think
sometimes we have political correctness
from both left and right
that are keeping our art forms from
being
free and you can say all you want about
hollywood being a
horrible place full of awful people and
it is
there's tons of terrible people here my
dad was a southern baptist minister
he used to rail against hollywood yeah
and i was just telling dad you know what
you're absolutely right i've been out
there
absolutely full of horrible evil people
you were totally right
talking in the pulpit yeah man i
couldn't have put it any better
but as milton said in
aeropotague you can't praise the
cloistered virtue you can't
say oh hollywood sucks we've got to shut
it down
they've done that in so many countries
in the world they don't have vibrant tv
industries
why is our entertainment industry why do
we sell all over the world
it's not because people love us they
hate america you know they think america
is awful
why does america sell all over the world
i think it's because
hollywood for all its faults doesn't get
its money from government
doesn't have a bunch of puritanical
judges saying
this you can say this you can't say this
it gets its power from people
paying money to see its product
no rules no regulation
it's the honestly it's it's the most
free market uh product produced by these
warm-hearted socialists at the top of
every uh economic entertainment company
they're the most cutthroat capitalists
on earth that's what i love hollywood
is it's anarchy at its best it has no
rules
so story is marching towards
more and more realistic ideas of what we
are as human beings and none of us are
real heroes
and none of us are real villains we're
all a mixture
where you have no rules you have
society's gangsters move in
right but i think that's where most
great art happens
and i also think that nobody really
knows how show business works
so part of the reason i think you guys
do with the work you do is so good is
everyone's saying
how does hollywood work where are the
rules i want somebody to give me
the way things work and what i think you
have to say to people is
guess what there aren't any rules in
this field
this is shadow town
this is where you have to make up your
own rules
nothing's going to be given to you
there's no school you can go
to little dupont go here you go there's
your showbiz degree
now you can go get a job here's the
field here's the desk here's your office
after 20 years you get a pension now
this is for chancers
this industry is for unhealthy people
who are deeply damaged and hurt by life
and they want to create story
uh for a variety of terrible reasons
but i think out of that comes the
greatest
art i think it's always been that way i
don't know which
french guy said it but he said art is a
sewer
and from the sewer emerges gold and i
think that's hollywood
it's never gonna be a place of healthy
people
doing things and and i don't know that
you should get in it if your goal is to
lead
a healthy productive life with
predictable
outcomes where at the end of your life
you're going
well that's great i've got my pension
i'm going to retire now i'm going to
go to florida everything's great i've
got my health insurance and that's why
that this town is not for you
and i i think that's just always going
to be the way it is
art's dangerous and scary and it's made
by dangerous and scary people
and he says hi elliot
we've been waiting for you the real
villain
has won and the story has just
begun this guy's is fabulous television
using all the patterns of the mystery
thriller and all the patterns
i've taught you right now this is what's
happening in television today
this is why television is so good
every desire is an ability is an attempt
to
supporterize the
wound to to to palliate
the wound nice
oh you're going to tell me something
that's gossip oh i want to hear
why because it's embarrassing
it's true and it's weird that's
every great story